- I filled in for you when you were gone.
- And you almost did too well, Kelly.
- Oh, whatever, I felt nervous.
I was like, who fills in
for fricking Simon Cowell?
- Well I gotta hand it
to you, because you know,
we were a bit of a loose end
and someone said, you know
do you think Kelly would do it?
I said, I promise you if
Kelly's free, she'll do it.
And I was watching
literally in bed that night.
And I'm thinking, thank you.
And as I'm watching it,
I'm thinking you're
actually doing too well here
- You're dumb.
- That's true.
I did not, I will tell you this though,
I did put on a little British
accent for this little thing.
- I'd like to hear that again, please.
- Would you you like to
see it? Yes, it's great.
I don't like it.
I love it.
Except I need glasses and a black shirt,
but I'm missing that.
And then wait, there's another one.
It's what the bloody hell was that?
I have the worst British
accent in the entire universe.
I don't do accents.
That was dreadful.
It was dreadful.
(laughing and clapping)
Let me do one in return,
let me try and do an American,
give me something American to say.
I can give you Texan.
- Okay, I'll do Texan.
- How y'all doing?
- Nope. (laughing)
- How y'all doing, I
think I want a barbecue.
- Nope, where are you from, the Bayou?
- Yeah I'd like a barbecue,
I'd like some ribs.
- Okay, you're about as
good as my accent, Simon.